true story in the news this week doctors
performed the world's first successful
penis and scrotum transplant on a US
soldier this is a true story yeah yeah
it's amazing now the reason I bring it
up is before we get into the whole
Avengers thing whatever I thought I
thought it was very cool my producer
just told me about 10 minutes ago that
the man who donated that penis and
scrotum is in our audience tonight this
is a true story yeah there is
the sir let me get this straight you
donated your penis and scrotum to the
soldier is that right yes I did enjoy
them young man well good for you but the
question is why did you do it
the man needed a penis and the scrotum
and I had a penis in the scrotum
okay that's fair but still it's a
tremendous sacrifice yeah you know what
the real sacrifice is what that soldier
and other soldiers go through defending
our country the real hero was on that
operating team okay well that's that's
very cool and I I do agree but Sir don't
you need your penis and scrotum of
course I do
I miss them terribly but I'll just pee
in this diaper until my penis grows back
sorry sir I'm sorry I hate to break the
news to you but penises don't grow back
oh really
genius you don't think I checked Siri
can human penises regenerate human
penises can regenerate or so I thought
until yesterday but I was wrong human
penises do not regenerate what are you
saying
yesterday was a busy day my mistake
Siri I'm right 70% of the time
you
you